el 30 de diciembre de 2011 Kim Jong
subió al poder en Corea del Norte su
ascenso se dio apenas dos semanas
después de la repentina muerte de su
padre Kim Jong de apenas 28 años su
figura era prácticamente desconocida
pero El Heredero al poder pronto dio
muestras de que seguiría la línea de su
padre al continuar con el programa
nuclear a nivel interno empezó a aplicar
su propio criterio y en 2013 ejecutó a
su tío y mano derecha de su padre Jason
taek por alta traición durante años un
aislamiento internacional casi completo
marcó su mandato algo que no impidió que
desarrollara su principal prioridad el
programa nuclear en 2017 se anunció el
primer misil intercontinental norcoreano
un avance que elevó la tensión con
Estados Unidos al máximo en años digo
todo Estados Unidos está dentro del
alcance de nuestras armas nucleares y el
botón nuclear está siempre en mi
escritorio
Esta es la realidad no una amenaza
pero en medio de esta retórica Kim abrió
un de diálogo con Corea del Sur que
llevó a la primera reunión en más de una
década con el presidente surcoreano
muniain la desnaclarización de Corea y
los diálogos para un acuerdo de paz
entre los dos países fueron los puntos
clave una reunión histórica que sirvió
para allanar el camino al encuentro con
el presidente estadounidense Donald
Trump fueron tres las cumbres con el
mandatario republicano pero pronto quedó
en evidencia que las posiciones de ambos
estaban muy distantes
si Estados Unidos Calcula más la
paciencia de nuestro pueblo nos impone
algo y persigue sanciones y presiones
sin cumplir una promesa que hizo frente
al mundo no tenemos más opción que
explorar un nuevo camino para proteger
nuestra soberanía
tras estos acercamientos fallidos Kim
reanudó el desarrollo nuclear y las
pruebas los últimos dos años de su
gobierno han estado marcados por un
aislamiento a un mayor a causa de la
pandemia y por los rumores que circulan
acerca de su mal estado de salud
motivados por sus largas ausencias en
actos públicos